California was one of the first states
to suffer an outbreak of the corona
virus under lockdown the numbers went
down but now they are back up along with
the hospitalizations Carter Evans has
that part of the story from Santa Monica
we're still in the first wave of this
pandemic California Governor Gavin
Newsom says a record number of people in
the state tested positive this week for
corona virus Richard good eye is from
South Los Angeles you feel like you're
going to die the virus spread to nearly
30 members of his extended family
including children like my kids are five
and two minus two Richard believes his
father brought the virus home from a
routine medical visit he thinks other
relatives became infected after some
visited his home and then brought the
virus back to their families
Richard was hospitalized when he found
out his father was taken to the ICU
where he died did you ever get to talk
to him again he worries people aren't
getting the message in Santa Cruz even
though cases are rising Health
Department officials say it's become
impossible to keep people off the
beaches people are willing to be any
more in that regard what do you want to
tell the people about this disease I
really want to address the non-believers
I plead with you I beg you to follow the
protocols please wear your mask it's a
real thing and unfortunately many people
aren't going to learn until it hits home
well the governor says the surge in
cases here in California could force 11
counties are about half the state's
population to pause they're reopening
plans he's also declaring a financial
budget emergency right now and pulling
eight billion dollars from a reserve
fund to pay for costs from the corona
virus Anthony Carter thank you